VILIFYING TODAY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHAT A PREDICTABLE TURN FROM
NANCY PELOSI TODAY.
WELL, SHE AND HER CAUCUS OF
COURSE HAVE SPENT THE BETTER
PART OF TWO YEARS CLAIMING THAT
DONALD TRUMP AND PUTIN ARE
BASICALLY SPOONING TOGETHER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP OBVIOUSLY
SEEMED FRIGHTENED IN THE
PRESENCE OF PUTIN.
WHAT WAS HE AFRAID OF?
WHAT IS PUTIN BLACKMAILING
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH?
>> THE ONLY LEADER HE IS TOTALLY
TRUE TO IS PUTIN.
>> I'VE SEEN PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE A LAWYER
AND YOU DON'T NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
>> FROM AN INTELLIGENCE
PERSPECTIVE, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS PUTTING AMERICA
FIRST, NOT RUSSIA.
>> Laura: WELL, GLENN
GREENWALD.
IF TRUMP IS LITERALLY CONTROLLED
BY PUTIN, TO THE POINT WHERE
TRUMP IS FORCED TO ACT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF RUSSIA AT THE
EXTENT OF THE U.S. WHICH HAS
BEEN THE PREVAILING CLAIM, NOT
OF DEMOCRATIC FRENCH IS BUT IT'S
MAINSTREAM, HOW CAN IT BE
MORALLY JUSTIFIED NOT TO IMPEACH
HIM?
WELL, NANCY.
TODAY PELOSI SAID IN A NEW
INTERVIEW KNOW TO IMPEACHMENT,
ADDING "HE'S NOT WORTH IT."
WAIT A SECOND.
IS NANCY TALKING ABOUT TRUMP OR
MUELLER?
BECAUSE NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL MAY COME UP
EMPTY ON THIS COLLUSION DEAL.
SO NANCY JUST WANTS TO MOVE ON
FROM THAT TO JUST PLAIN OLD
REGULAR DEMONIZING TRUMP 24/7.
OF COURSE PELOSI AND COMPANY
WILL GET PLENTY OF HELP FROM
THEIR STATE RUN MEDIA OUTLETS
ALL THE WAY THROUGH ELECTION
2020.
>> HE HAS MORE THAN 10,000 LIVES
RACKED UP ALREADY.
>> DON'T FORGET HE SAID IT INTO
DAYS.
>> LIES, OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> RACISM, WHITE NATIONALISM.
>> Laura: SZABO LINSKY WOULD
BE VERY PROUD, KIDS.
THE RUTHLESS DEMONIZATION
DOESN'T STOP WITH OUR CURRENT
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP BECAUSE
WHAT THE LEFT WANTS IS A TOTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE REMAKING OF OUR HISTORY.
ENTER STAGE LEFT.
THEIR NEW SOCIALIST POSTER CHILD
IS NOT ONLY CLAIMING THAT FDR'S
NEW DEAL WAS RACIST BUT THAT
RONALD REAGAN WAS RACIST TOO.
>> I THINK A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
HOW SPECIAL INTERESTS AND THE
POWERFUL HAVE PITTED WHITE
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS AGAINST
BROWN AND BLACK WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS IS REAGANISM IN THE
'80s WHEN HE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT WELFARE.
PAINTING THIS RESENTFUL VISION
OF ESSENTIALLY BLACK WOMEN WHO
WERE DOING NOTHING, THEY WERE
SOCKS ON OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: TO THINK I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT THE WORD SOCKS COULD
BE USED AS A NOUN.
LEARN SOMETHING NEW EVERY DAY.
TO THINK THAT THEY ACTUALLY
LINED UP AROUND THE BLOCK TO
HEAR THAT SEARING INTELLECT.
WELL, WITH SUCH GRATUITOUS
MEANNESS ABOUT ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED PRESIDENTS OF THE PAST
50 YEARS, THE SxSW FESTIVAL
SHOULD BE RENAMED, I DON'T KNOW,
THE MOUTH AND MOUTH WORSE
FESTIVAL.
AS WE DOCUMENTED HERE ON THE
ANGLE WEEK AFTER WEEK MONTH
AFTER MONTH, THERE'S A CONCERTED
ACROSS-THE-BOARD EFFORT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO DEMONIZE THE
ENTIRE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE AND
THE AMERICAN TRADITION BY
DEGRADING ANYONE AND ANYTHING
THAT DOESN'T PASS THEIR OWN
RADICAL MONSTER.
REMEMBER, THE KIDS OF THE
MOMENT, THEY CAN BE THE LEADERS
OF TOMORROW, GOD HELP US.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT
MERELY DISMISSED THESE EPISODES.
IN FACT ANYONE INTERESTED IN
PRESERVING OUR FREEDOM AND OUR
FREE MARKET, NOT TO MENTION THE
HISTORICAL RECORD, MUST USE
THESE MOMENTS TO TEACH A NEW
GENERATION THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
COUNTRY WE LOVE.
OUR TRIUMPHS AND THE TRAGEDIES
THAT WE SHOULD LEARN FROM.
BUT IN THE VISION VICIOUS
LANDSCAPE OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA WR
LANDSCAPE OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA WD
LANDSCAPE OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA W,
UNTRUTHS BECOME TRUTHS IF THEY
GO UNCORRECTED.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
DO EVEN REALLY HAVE FREE SPEECH
IN AMERICA TODAY?
IF MILLIONS OF YOU FEEL AFRAID
TO SPEAK YOUR MIND FOR FEAR OF
BEING DEMONIZED AT WORK.
AT SCHOOL, AT YOUR UNIVERSITIES,
EVEN IN THE MILITARY.
ON THE LEFT, THE IMPULSE TODAY
IS TO CONTROL SPEECH, NOT
ENCOURAGE MORE OF IT.
CNN PRESIDENT JEFF ZUCKER WAS
ALSO AT THAT SxSW FESTIVAL
JUSTIFYING THE DNC'S DECISION TO
DENY FOX A CHANCE TO HOST A
DEMOCRAT DEBATE.
HE BASICALLY SAID NO ONE HAS THE
RIGHT TO GET A DEBATE AND THEN
HE WENT ON TO SAY WELL, LET'S
KEEP SCROLLING.
THEY SAID LOOK, FOX'S BASICALLY
BASICALLY STATE RUN TV.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO GIVE WANDA FOX.
I THINK THE QUESTION SHOULD BE,
IS FOX STATE RUN TV OR BLAH
BLAH.
REJOINDER QUESTION.
HAS CNN BECOME RESISTANT TV?
WHERE THE PRESIDENT AND BY
ASSOCIATION A HUGE SWATH OF
AMERICANS WHO VOTED FOR HIM ARE
TREATED LIKE EVIL NEANDERTHALS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PROPOSING
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE IT'S IN KEEPING WITH
AMERICAN TRADITION WHEN IT COMES
TO IMMIGRATION.
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY SAYS GIVE
ME YOUR TIRED, YOUR POOR, YOUR
HUDDLED MASSES YEARNING TO
BREATHE FREE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS POISONING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S GETTING WORSE EVERY DAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
WE ALREADY KNEW THAT.
>> THIS MAKE AMERICA GREAT HAT
IS JUST AS MADDENING AND
FRUSTRATING AND TRIGGERING FOR
ME TO LOOK AT AS A KKK HOOD.
>> Laura: THIS IS CNN.
WORD IS JAMES EARL JONES GO TO
GET HIS VOICE-OVER BACK AFTER
THAT THING?
IS IT ANY WONDER CNN IS FACING A
$250 MILLION LAWSUIT FOR
DEFAMING THE REPUTATION OF    OH
DEFAMING THE REPUTATION OF    OS
DEFAMING THE REPUTATION OF    OE
COVINGTON CATHOLIC STUDENTS?
THE NETWORK ROUTINELY ALLOWS ITS
IDEOLOGY TO ECLIPSE FACTS AND
THEN THE DEMONIZATION GAME SOON
BEGINS.
A FEW WEEKS AGO, CNN ACTUALLY
HIRED SARAH IS GOOD FOR US,
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFE
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFS
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFI
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFN
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFS
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFO
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFE
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFW
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFM
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFN
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFH
HARVARD LAW GRAD AND FORMER JEFE
OF JUSTICE.
SHE WAS HIRED, SURPRISING TO ME,
AS A CNN POLITICAL EDITOR.
WHAT WAS CNN THINKING HIRING A
CONSERVATIVE?
THE ANNOUNCEMENT SENT
SHOCK WAVES.
LIBERAL GERBIL JOURNALS MY
BANANAS, STARTING WRITING PIECES
MALIGNING HER.
MY QUESTION IS DID SHE LOCK MORE
JOURNALISTIC EXPERIENCE THAN
THESE PEOPLE?
YOU CAN SEE THEM ON THE SCREEN.
THEY WERE GRANTED NETWORK
PURCHASE AFTER THEIR POLITICAL
STANCE.
NO.
GET THE DNC WAS QUICK TO
REGISTER ITS DISPLEASURE WITH
HER IN THAT ROLE OF POLITICAL
EDITOR AT THAT NETWORK.
DEMOCRAT CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE AIDE
TOLD "THE DAILY BEAST" CHAIRMAN
TOM PEREZ IN THE DNC EXPRESSED A
CNN THAT THEY HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH A HIGHER.
THEY CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
NETWORK ABOUT HOW THIS IMPACTS
2020.
AS OF WEDNESDAY, THEY GOT
ASSURANCES THAT SHE WOULD NOT BE
INVOLVED IN DEBATES.
NOT ONLY THAT.
JEFF ZUCKER DEMOTED HIS GIRDER
TO A MERE POLITICAL CONTRIBUTOR.
SHE WILL HAVE ZERO ROLE IN
SHAPING THE COVERAGE OF THE
DEMOCRATS OR THEIR DEBATES.
THE GOOD NEWS IS NORTH WATCHING
CNN SO DOESN'T REALLY MATTER.
SO I'VE GOT A QUESTION.
WILL SOME CRACK LIBERAL
JOURNALIST WRITE A LONG TEDIOUS
MAGAZINE PIECE ABOUT HOW CNN IS
THE MOUTHPIECE WITH A DIRECT
LINE INTO THE DNC AND VICE
VERSA?
NO, DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
TACTIC.
THE LEFT IS COMMITTED TO
DISTORTING HISTORY AND
DISTORTING THE PAST WHILE
DEMONIZING ANYONE AND
EVERYONE STANDS UP FOR AMERICAN
VALUES AND TRADITIONS.
WHAT STARTED AS THE REMOVAL OF
HISTORICAL MONUMENTS HAS NOW
BECOME A FULL ON ASSAULT ON
PRESIDENTIAL LEGACIES AND THE
MOVEMENTS, NAMELY THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT, THAT WAS
CREATED.
AND BY THE WAY, IF A
CONSERVATIVE DOES MANAGE TO
SECURE A POST INSIDE ONE OF
THESE OLD DINOSAUR BASTIONS, HE
OR SHE WILL BE VILIFIED,
CONDEMNED WITHOUT CAUSE, AND
DRIVEN OUT.
BECAUSE THE FANATICAL LEFT,
WELL, IT'S NO LONGER ABOUT
WINNING IN THE ARENA OF IDEAS
FOR THEM.
IT'S NO LONGER A DEBATE, AND MAY
THE BEST PERSON WHEN.
NO, NO, NO.
INSTEAD, THEY WORK TO TAKE
PLAYERS OFF THE FIELD WITH
BLINDSIDE HITS.
>> HEY, BUDDY.
>> Laura: BUT JUST NOT THAT
FUNNY.
IF DEMOCRATS WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE, I HAVE A SUGGESTION.
WHY NOT STARTING ENGAGING
INCIDENT DEMONIZING.
YOU'RE WELCOME ON THE SHOW
ANYTIME.
HOW'S THAT FOR OPENNESS?
MEANWHILE DEMOCRATS ORALLY HAVE
ANY DEFENSE, DO THEY COME UP FOR
WHAT'S, LET'S ANNA BOERNER.
NOR ARE THEY GOING TO TRY TO
CONVINCE VOTERS THAT THEY'LL DO
A BETTER JOB AT LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD WITH CHINA AND
FORCING FAIRNESS IN TRADE.
OR MAYBE HOW THEY WOULD RAISE
YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING OR HAVE
A STRONGER ECONOMY THAN TRUMP.
YOU KNOW EITHER POINT TO NOT
MAKE THAT ARGUMENT?
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
ALL THEY REALLY HAVE LEFT IS
SOME ITERATION OF "YOU ARE A
RACIST IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH